yeah hello welcome to a new video this
will be somewhat different to the ones
before and I'll be doing a quick recap
of my first three games here at the
European lockup played in Slovenia um a
very strong tournament of course and
yeah the first we ransom have been great
in terms of results with my play I'm not
completely satisfied
strangely enough because um there were
quite a lot of errors but well the
opponents didn't play perfect that I
didn't play perfectly as well so result
wise it was very nice
so let's start with the first game um
yeah my team is seeded number 40 or 39
I'm not quite sure
among 60 teams so first round met meant
that we got some very strong opposition
and this was in fact the team from
Ukraine I'm not sure and there maybe
there's more than one team but this is
the strongest one from Ukraine they got
six players rated above 2600 on one
players to 590 or something but all very
very good player some I play and play
about two in my team so my opponent is
rated 2666 and its name is Yuri crevo
rants is correctly at least half way I'm
a preparation mum I look at his games
and he's got a pretty steady opening
repertoire and so I could prepare
something but in fact after a couple of
moose I forgot my preparation and was on
my own so let's just start with the game
with them alright f3 and he goes 4c 5c
496 he did this a couple of times
already in his in his games lad c3 and
now he am slightly surprised me with
with g6 here um in his game see miles
went 45 here which usually continues g3
g6 Bishop g2 Bishop g7 and I did some
preparation for this line but now he
went for on g6 um actually this line
doesn't have such a great reputation um
mostly because of the movie 3 here which
after Bishop g7 d4 is just a bit better
for white because the knight on c6 is
just a bad piece which will be attacked
with d5 um but there's this slight issue
with this line the setup Bishop g7 like
also my play and Knight f6 here which
after d4 CDE DD 5 seat XD 595 leads to
position on which user knee which one
which can arise also um from you for
opening the caro-kann um this is
believed to be better for white but it's
a bit yeah it's a bit of strange
positionally I can show you the main
line here it's a little trickier because
of f7 but I cannot save his Knight but
you can play Knight to d5 Bishop takes 6
takes c6 b c6 and then for instance
let's say castles 25 Queen somewhere I'm
not sure Quincy 3 maybe and this is some
real position which is pretty unbalanced
Black's got the bishop am ok
seven or c8 Bishop which will go to b7
soon it's not the greatest peace but if
black manages to place his 65 his his
really okay but white also has got ideas
to play against c6 or maybe play Bishop
f4 to e5 this idea actually means that
black will often play even even f7 f6
here it's a bit of an unclear position
and I didn't really want to go into this
so um when he went for g6 I just decided
to play g3 anyway hoping that we were
transposed to the line I had prepared
Bishop g7 now Bishop d2 and now he five
he just transposed to the variation he
had played them in the other move order
um okay um castles my g7 83 castles
would be one a fives already pretty
normal a5 of course to prevent white
from playing a before no 91 it's
important to play this immediately and
not waste any time I'm on d6 let's say D
3 D 3 d6 night e1 maybe Bishop e6 not c2
and now black manages to play d5 in this
erm is pretty okay with playing that e1
immediately um after d6 night C 2 B
should be 693 I managed to prevent him
from playing G 65 and make sure that I
get a knight on d5 now he goes for f5 a
95 and f4 the pretty aggressive way to
to play this Oh d3 is logical and now I
play d5 I actually had this position in
the preparation and here I wanted to
play III um III year which is a solid
move to
and black from further expanding on the
kingside has it put some pressure on
their form let's say wants to play g4 I
just just take on that phone this is a
solid move it also prevents him from
playing Knight g4 at some point which
could be an idea um but okay I forgot my
preparation and went for for p4 which
also seems to be okay you know took here
a B and not to convey form yeah now I'm
I think I didn't play it didn't play it
a good here I'm sorry I just should just
take on before now and this purpose
position should be well slightly better
for white maybe because b7 is is a weak
pawn and I have a nice controller of the
long diagonal here the bishop on g2 is
really strong but I went for a
four-night b5 which is an idea as saw in
the preparation but in some slightly
different position only I thought it was
interesting but well it doesn't it
doesn't really give white much rook c8
of course he needs to cover c7 now I
went for Bishop d2 which is or was the
idea behind all this
I'm 95 mm-hmm and I he played rook f7
which was I think a solid move to cover
the seventh rank and to get some
flexibility maybe Bishop f8 could be an
idea to cover d6 at some point I think
it's a good - multifunctional move and
now I should I think still play III here
just just waiting a bit what he's doing
because well he doesn't have such a
great move that he can play here because
well the natural move on Queen d7 assume
of course
stands with not be sick so I'm not sure
what what you should play here maybe
just some some more preparation but I
think if the threes move that helps me
and he doesn't have something great to
do but I I pretty quickly took on on B
form
now it takes rook takes Knight takes CD
five what we should be 5/4 was an
alternative but I didn't want to give up
this bishop as a protection piece for
the King
oh it's shipped it's playable but well I
didn't want to go for this CD no Bishop
c4 yeah this is an interesting position
well he's got a bed Bishop on g7 but I
have to Schneider on b5 which is also
whilst a little bit of a strange piece
it looks active and at x d6 but it
doesn't do much more than that and I
wasn't I wasn't sure how to hard to
continue in this position I went for a
really a controversial move here but I'm
not sure the computer actually suggests
just to play h3 here
the bishop h5 or f5 it it's not much of
a difference and then it wants to play G
form bishop g6 Queen b3 and things that
why does slightly better yeah thought of
this briefly but well I still couldn't I
couldn't bring myself to play h3 and g4
that looked a bit weakening but yeah
maybe it is in fact a somewhat better
for white I just like I don't know
Bishop f3 and then maybe return the
night walk from b5 to c3 and then you
for something yeah it looks nice if you
in analysis it looks nice but in the
game I couldn't couldn't really bring
myself to do this I had the idea to play
D form and well I added played you form
the ideas
either to to get the squared D for for
the night and then go to e6 if possible
for instance if he if he plays really
okay it's bad presence but let's just
show it then I'll have the idea to UM to
to get the night to e6 which is of
course very nice if I manage this he
couldn't tolerate the night here and
most likely would need to take this off
and then I will get a very strong bishop
in g2 and this this was the the basic
idea as thought that the alternative to
well that if he let me let me take on d4
and takes with the pawn I would get a
nice passed pawn to d6 to come so for
instance he playing here at queen is
heaven and let's say de okay to put the
bishop but let's just say this this kind
of position should be very nice for
white with a great Bishop on G tomb ok
played Queen e7 and now I took which
well fits with a plan took with the
bishop and well now I cannot play on
whoops I played this one cannot play
this immediately because he it just
takes and eg was hanging so I need to
attend this first um yeah he now
exchanged on f3 I think this is fine he
could also play Bishop h3 for instance
after which I just dropped this back um
yeah he took here which is I think it's
ok
and now played rook c5 and well after
the game we just talked briefly um about
it he thought this was was a mistake and
he should play something else
unfortunately I could not really
understand what movie em suggested we
talked briefly in English but his accent
was so strong that I didn't I didn't get
what you wanted to play um yeah the
problem with this move is is my response
which pretty much
kills the game in terms of any chances
for black to win it on I played a 94
here which is I think pretty strong the
the problem here is of course d5 is
hanging I can show it briefly and what
happens if he takes it and he got the
problem he cannot allow to to get the
knight to allow me to get the knight who
is 6 of course um let's have a look at
at the line he just took on g3 first
which okay it's make sense to was the
edge pawn and now he decided to who to
take this I dove so let's just have a
look what happens if he it takes on d5
so nice line not f5 of course was the
idea
the discovery um ok needs to play Queen
e6 to to cover the rook let h6 check
she looks looks a bit strange this
desperado night King g7 and now Queen b3
yeah he missed that he told me told me
that after the game this much I could
understand
King h6 and now look b5 to see idea to
to pin the rook on the Queen a strange
configuration of pieces he cannot unpin
this in fact black has has a draw here
he can he can take him funny move the
idea is to get Queen h3 and so rook t5
Queen edge v FG Queen takes King h1 rook
F for that looks a bit like I'm I'm get
him mated but I've got this another cool
move from g4 group text you for Queen f7
and it's a perpetual yeah this would
have been a nice finish but I think it
actually he should do this because what
he's playing I just it's a bit risky him
um after this wide already is a little
bit better
whoopty form
and now I think he made a slight mistake
Queen f6 I think it's a bit better here
you play troop see for me after which I
have well it's not difficult to find but
it's it's rather strong f4 which gets
rid of the f3 weakness he now took on f4
and offered the draw and ok this is
typical situation you got a better
position against a much stronger player
and what I calculated a couple of lines
and at the end I decided to take it and
maybe I shouldn't I shouldn't do this
because it's um it's pretty much
unlikely that white could lose lose the
game anymore can have a quick look here
ok of course I play Quincy form and then
well to two lines
route route g7 as one possibility and
then take he and the computer actually
suggests Queen e5 him to give up a pawn
essentially and get into an end came
like this of course so this I wouldn't
have what I wouldn't take a draw in this
endgame but my black has of course some
good chances to to to hold this you know
this would have been nice I was more
worried about something like King h8
look at for rupees 17 h5 this kind of
position wide wide is of course better
I've got the better King position the
King is much safer and I also have ideas
to to use the weak square on e6 on the
other hand he's got the b-pawn which
might be weak at some point but saw saw
passed pawn yeah it's some I think it's
it's better for white I wouldn't turn I
wouldn't draw this against we could play
him I wouldn't take a draw
that's a might will end in a draw but
there I wouldn't accept the draw from
yeah at the end I decided to take this
after a couple of minutes and okay it's
it's a great start if you
against a player with two 660 or
something so yeah this was okay um at
the end we we lost the match um with its
spread of six ports we lost the match
four and a half to one and a half we
made two three draws which was a great
result of course I'm okay this we were
all rated more than 200 points at our
board sometimes 300 points so three
draws was just just fine um okay the
loss at the first round of course meant
that we whoops just a second
um the loss of the first round of course
meant that we would get some weaker team
in the second round and as it happened
we got one of the weakest team so the
team from from Wales um they got one one
pretty good player with about 2,500 on
board one and the five other players are
rated about 2,000 or even even below
that so they're seated I don't know
among 60 teams 5050 9s or something okay
I got got black here just let me switch
the colors and my opponent was called
Jason Garcia is ready 2019 and he plays
you form
um of course I did some preparation for
this game as well and I noticed he is an
e4 only player I decided to go for the
Sicilian and and in the games I had in
the database he always played the open
Sicilian and I'm well I was glad to get
some yeah not symmetrical position and
try to to outplay him and go for win but
he opted for Bishop b5 which is well
very decent alternative of course the
deform
um I played d6 here and now he took on
c6 which is some pretty early it's it's
a playable move of course but mostly
white plays castles here or c3 moves
like this
okay takes here and then I think he he
played he played an already somewhat
passive move was d3 I think white should
play something like let's say castles
and if I go for you five now White has
got
c3 with the idea to get in a quick
deform and open up the position white is
better developed and he's got chances in
case of an opening of the position to to
play against the weakened pawns he on c6
and d6 maybe let's just say that's like
this d4 CDE CD and well black is not
really able to fight here in the center
because of the bad development I think I
would have played something else if he
went forth or castles or d3 was a bit of
an relief because now he 5s is a nice
move which blocks the center and if he
wants to open it up now it would cost
him a move now it castles and Bishop e7
here um yeah the reason for this is I
want I want to have the option of
playing f5 immediately to to open it up
for the two bishops now I went for h3
it's really passive move I'm not sure I
think it should still should try
something like c3 here
okay f5 it's not illogical it took now
she takes and now Knight h2 which well
doesn't look too great and he wants to
play a four to get some play in the
center and
yeah but the disadvantage of course is
it opens the position even more for the
bishops it takes F which it takes and
now I just cast out and I think
objectively this moves on flipping
better but I was well I was a bit
tempted by my little trap here this the
reason for for castling
I played nasty through now but the trap
I thought was if he takes now okay it's
rather simple but still I was tempted to
to get in this um King h1 and now 94
wins wins immediately not g3 mate
threatened Knight f2r and rook singing
well it's just what just resides here
okay Knight c3 I'm twenty-seven
normal move want to get in the rook on a
tour maybe roof f7 rook HOF eight and
also if I'm lucky I'm a able to be
sacrificed on h3 at some point when I
played Queen e2 which surprised me
because the Queen doesn't really be
longer than on the even if I am okay
rook to e8 and now I think it really
gets get problematic he plays g4 now was
just it's just weakens the King and he
doesn't really get anything in return
for this I think it just should just
play some Norman booth after which black
a slightly better with the bishops and
some advantage in the center I have been
ideas like d5c for and so on but at
least he wouldn't have a weakened King
no Bishop g6 Bishop e6 was also fine on
twin g2 and 95 you always need to be a
little bit careful about advancing the
pawns here um because it also weakens
some squares like a five and maybe
five but the problem is just very
concrete he plays okay one now and now
I've got a thing very pretty strong move
c4 which opens up the diagonal for the
bishop very nicely and this was also a
reason why I dropped the bishop to g6
because of this c4 idea like it's now
really clearly better the idea is if he
takes now on c4 a big mistake he didn't
do this I have Bishop c5 check King h1
exchange and now 94 and black is
completely winning I have from Knight f2
other threat the bishop hay is hanging
on f4 he just doesn't have a move the
system it's just over um so I'm but d3
is also just hanging I am threatened to
take this so I covered this with slide
g3 Queen g3 and now I have d4 91
Knight d5 which is very nice getting the
knight into play he needs to drop back
and now Bishop d6 checking the Queen
okay can flip this in and now Queen f3
needs to cover these three just take
Queen c7 h2 is hanging he doesn't have a
good move to protect us just this one
yeah this at this point I spent some
time I played the most before rather
quickly I don't know I only had to use
30 or 40 minutes here he had took some
time because I thought that there should
be a maid of win of a piece or something
but I didn't find anything and then just
played the simple line and the
alternative I had which I am sore but
and at the end decided against was
Bishop g3 rook g2
Bishop f4 was just continues to attack
here after the bishops I exchanged and I
get the nod on f4 and it's just a great
tech d3 is just hanging and yeah the
computer already gives an O plus four or
five or something it's just just a
direct win
um but okay I'm I I wasn't so completely
sure and and at the end I played rook f8
which just trades down to to this
position on with black being a pawn up
and still the bishop and why it's ugly
pieces it's just ajust a winning yeah
semi endgame I think I think we can go
and go over the rest of the news pretty
quickly out so we decided to just
exchange Queen cm and this is a pretty
pretty easy winning both black
centralizing you also need to know that
he was he that didn't have any time he
had just just seconds for for the last
couple of musa at the end position I
just attacked me through yen it cannot
be protected so yeah was a I think a
pretty pretty clean win that's still
still necessary to play hmm decent
Muslim against player with two thousand
waiting you see this in this tournament
it's it's really really interesting
they're on a couple of teams who have
players with very bad ratings like 2000
1900 were very bad in comparison to to
the other teams which have lots of
thailand players and so on but these
players sometimes do score pretty
heavily on there was one match which was
really amazing and it was played close
to two hour match where a team from
norway played the team from Turkey and
the Turkish players they had three
younger players on the last three boards
with 1,900 1,800 and
something like this and they scored
three wins those younger players were
this 2002 and 2003 hundred players so
you never know how well they they play
okay we wanted this match nicely with
four enough to 1 and our unfortunately
our first bought lost with us there
2,400 player and we conceded also one
draw so it was clear the third round we
would get some some better better team
and it turned out that we we got team
from from Hungarian or Hungary what's
what's in the English and a pretty
strong team with one grandmaster on
board one and a couple of other players
rated above 2400 my opponent was
international master kabocha Gabor
Kovich is rated 2490 something and
pretty much grandmaster strength but he
didn't get the title yet yeah did some
preparation of course and um notice that
he's got a pretty narrow opening
repertoire basically plays the same
lines all the time for years but it also
means that he's got some experience and
then a very solid player um okay let's
go through the first moves yeah he
basically always plays these four moves
against g4c for anything he just wants
to get a prince gambit declined type of
setup this is also why I decided to to
make exactly this move order to to get
the main line position of the cat
opening um not to conceive for which was
expected I had I don't know about 15 or
20 games of him in this line so it's got
quite some experience here but in all
games he got Quincy to on and I played
Queen f4 which just usually just the
transposition one point of Queen a
forest and Queen c2 um black has the
pretty new option to play b5 which is
well maybe maybe an unclear unclear line
then a four before and once it's
complicated um Queen air force is meant
to prevent this but now he surprised me
he didn't go for um for it's six which
is father main move Quincy for b5 Quincy
too and he already know B should be
seven and he already had this ten times
or so and I focused my whole preparation
on on this line of course it's a very
safe online where white now can choose
between the couple of moves basically
our moves that make sense here after
Bishop Bishop d2 Bishop f4 Bishop g5 and
yeah one one issue with black here is
some it is very difficult to play for
win here with black and okay he's out
writing me by about 100 points and
didn't have a great tournament so far I
played I think a drawing in the first
round against a rather an overrated
player and then lost in the second okay
well so very strong opponent I'm I
forgot some two thousand six hundred
plus player and I think he maybe wanted
to get more of a fighting game um so he
opted for something else he played
Bishop e7 on so it's a rare move to be
honest I think it's just a bad choice if
he wants
playful when you shouldn't go for the
setup at all because um let's let's just
go through a couple of museum um if you
look at the position we are getting now
white is just better here no doubt about
it
I just got advantage in the center and
yeah and it's not I think a position you
can you can play for win with black
really okay you always can try to but
it's it's it's risky why this is better
yeah my plan I played a rookie one here
this is also pretty much uncharted
territory there are only one or two
games in the database
rookie one this was meant to watch
ephors Knight c5 um actually I stopped
calculating here but this is playable
for white I could try to just play this
year and 95 I'm I didn't bother to
calculate this um I just thought Rocky
one is it smooth that p1 here is a move
I I'm I can I think it's useful move
anyway
no one rook e8 e for b6 to get a place
on b7 for the bishop it's all very
natural here we should F for Bishop e7
rook anyone just tantalizing now Quincy
eight yeah thought he he wants to maybe
prepare c5 here and I want to play of
course if you play see if I want to play
d5 so I played Queen c2 here too yeah
let me show you what happens if I don't
play this
let's say H 4 which is also normal
decent mafia c5 d5 and I was got c4
which in itself it's maybe not not
dramatic but I didn't want to give him
this was with the tempo so I decided to
drop them the Queen back here and now as
I think he played AB and move just
simple as that
um I'm not sure what what to recommend
you for blankets it's just really not a
very enterprising position and you
cannot do much yeah I think c5 if you
play c5 let's just say let's say c5 d5
this is better for white because of the
D pawn and also one one interesting idea
to note here is the Bishop one going to
h3 which puts lots of pressure here on
the knee six and this position of the
Queen I'm not sure maybe he should just
I don't know 15 I have eight or
something
Bishop f8 well he went for b5 and yeah
no I think I did I didn't play the best
movie him I like this move I have plenty
5 for him no just I like this move
because it it looked it looked very
active with the ideas of Knight d4 maybe
that c6 at some point and also I wanted
to to get these ideas in after a takes
d5 it takes d5 like Nagi five pitch of
h3 but I can just play our look b1 here
a six a four was with a positional
advantage this is much much cleaner I
should I should play this white is just
better he has really huge problems to
defend the Queen side and white has a
pretty much easy game here I should play
this d5 this is worse but okay it leads
to an interesting position but it's it's
not the best move he took now and now
Bishop e6 this is actually a move I am
yeah and estimated in a couple of lads I
don't think it's the best move no but
underestimated is this simple idea what
he should do actually I think this Bush
is Knight to f6 and let's say Queen
ninety-five
I was attracted to this idea because um
wide also got the idea of playing Bishop
83 now that's just a fantasy line let's
say just one h6
Bishop h3 green here and at night f7
just just to show what kind of ideas
there are four White King takes
we should check King pick and this one
it can be pretty pretty quickly of
course this is a very bad play but just
to show what ideas are armed
you should play now here Bishop d6 and
now let's say who takes Bishop e3 with
the idea of Bishop g4 maybe now h6 and
something like this it's it's still I
think a bit more comfortable for white
but black is pretty solid here it's very
helpful that he's got rid enough got rid
of the night which so it's annoying to
to go from d4 to to c6 and so on um yeah
this should be okay chef here on this on
this move around here would be not b6
after which I have a nice smooth a form
very strong let's say he takes us we've
got c4 the idea of c5 it's very strong
or night a4 also Seaforths it's very
nice because the knight aside land on a
form yeah this defect was interesting
but well if he defends correctly I think
this is okay
he played and well Bishop d6 now I have
changed here and now Knight d4 white is
still somewhat somewhat better but the
other lines were just clear on this one
Queen b3 a six and A four yeah and now
we we produce
couple of a couple of errors in a row
what you should do now is in this
position you should exchange only one
which doesn't make the most logical
impression but it's it's it's the
correct move takes here but it's all
because of a trick and I think we both
missed this Knight f6 now d5 is hanging
so I take on b5 a matrix B Knight takes
Bishop take this is all forced and now
looked u1 this was my calculation and I
think also his calculation and I thought
okay I win the d6 pawn here and okay
it's a pawn up and you can try to win
this not sure if if White will manage
but it's just an extra pawn and no
problems the Black has got the funny
move 93-year I think we just both myths
missed that and if I take now it's a
perpetual check really strange one but
it's a perpetual sorry and he just
missed it missed this and and I also so
if a tonight f6 immediately here no I
took on b5 which is also wrong I should
exchange on yet first and now he retakes
you also did this immediately if he
takes on you one now we are back in the
line I showed before the difference is
now I can take which I should have done
before rookie AIDS and queen bee five
and it's it's just an extra pawn here um
he could actually play Bishop b5 now
maybe he should do this but it's it's of
course not a decision you really like to
like to make this kind of this kind of
line were just white as an extra pawn in
technical position it's the clear
advantage not sure it is completely
winning or something but
yeah maybe you should try to defend this
but it's thankless tasks of course he
went back to c7 on my just went see for
him and this is an extra porn with
pretty much clear advantage because also
the b7 bishop is quite a bad piece at
the moment and I always have to said yes
of knight c6 and this is just an
annoying piece on c6 and then I'll I've
had years of c5 I just need to be
careful that he doesn't manage to get
some brocade like night on c5 Bishop on
g7 and then it's difficult to make
progress but it's it's pretty pretty
quick here on bishop c8 yep and h3 to
cover the g4 square 97
Bishop d7 and 96 yeah I think I just
planned to play c5 here or maybe maybe
just also Queen a 5-2 to get the Queen's
off the d6 pawn is also weakness um
imagine he made a mistake now Quincy age
okay it's a it's easy to make bet moves
in such a position just Queen deform he
cannot take on h3 because t6 is hanging
and t6 is also not not really a pawn you
can cover easily so I went back back
Queen c7 and I okay one this is this is
a winning position now rook s7 is just
just deadly now and he took now on c6
not not an easy decision of course
because I get this pawn here and now
King f8 and now the time trouble
mistakes come yeah I didn't I didn't
have so much time left and I also to
admit I was really nervous so um I
played okay five here was just just
useless move just Queen d7 it's just
winning I'm not I'm not sure what what I
actually missed there because it's
really easy if he takes now
this is just winning and he doesn't
really have have something else because
I always have Luca a seven like group
see a truck a seven and and resins
basically this would have been much
faster of course I'm not sure what I
what I didn't like about Queen b7 it's
just I didn't have so much time left but
I'm not sure I've lied rook air-five the
idea was Rock b5 and then looked b7
which is also not bad what White's
position is so winning that I can I can
play a couple of second red moves and
still keep the winning position King
edge - he's our all-time trouble move
now he's got this one yeah but this is
the position of course and he's close to
being in zooms one Bishop f3 it's not
the best Bishop t5 is better I just
wanted to keep keep the position somehow
and time trouble
Bishop d5 now is also better 19 b5 now
we actually can open up the position a
bit and threaten was was checks maybe
you the Queen take is here and King G to
to prevent the Queen exchange and now we
we got the 40 moves in this is of course
a zero move it doesn't doesn't help much
I realized immediately drop drop back
yeah
you know white white has some quicker
wins here but I think this is it is
still enough black cannot do much
because it's a it's so passive and it
just needs to protect all the other all
the threats iam 27 2005 King g7 we
should be for to get the night Queen to
h7 maybe Queen f4 and this
finally finally winning bishop h7 King
h8 and now it's funny I just I just
missed the made in three year I played
Rock g5 and white can just just play
this one and it's just a maid but after
rook g5 okay it's completely winning
Bishop g8 threatened Queen f8 still
threatened and so on he just he just
resigned here so it and also winning
quickly it's also um it's the first time
that I play with this time control and
it's something you really not need to
get used to the time control is 90
minutes for forty moves and 30 seconds
increment so if you add it all up for 40
moves you've got 10 minutes less than
usual if you are used to two hours for
40 moves but the difference to two other
time controls are played before us that
after the 40 moves you can get 3 to 30
minutes for the rest of the game and the
30 second increments oh so in this game
for instance after 40 moves I'd spent
all my time I was basically down in a
couple of seconds so I get 30 minutes
and this 30 second and increment so for
instance in this game after move 45 or
46 or so I was already down to 5 or 6
minutes for the rest of the game can you
get the increment but it said something
you need to get used to him yeah ok this
is some where the first three games I'm
pretty successful start I think yeah
still I made a couple of errors in this
in this game I'm not really satisfied
then I didn't finish this off cleaner
but okay it was so bad that it it was
hard to to spoil it completely um yeah
yeah well I hope it was interesting to
to look through the games and yeah
please leave any questions
comments here on YouTube and also think